hi everyone I'm machine from Hattie's
games today I'm going to talk about our
test project the next-generation
automated test for games two month ago
on GDC we launched an open-source this
project so how many of you here have
heard of it oh pretty much okay today
I'm going to talk about these three
topics challenges in game testing and
how our test project can help you solve
these problems and also our internal
practice of large scale real device
testing so the first issue is that we
have so many games to test in that it's
games this our games we developed and
released since 2014 we have released
over 150 mobile games and also we have
run several PC games for over 10 years
so how do we ensure the high quality of
all these games
another issue is Android device
fragmentation and because Android system
is vessels and OMS can customize their
own Android phones and this graph shows
the situation in China you can see
Samsung Hawaii show me each have
thousands of Android models and each
model has different screen resolution
different system api's or even graph
drivers in that exclaims we usually need
to test over more than 200 Android
phones before releasing a game then
let's take a look at the difference of
testing between apps and games the first
one is usually our app our games are
released on multiple platforms like
Android iOS the same game work
version of game on different platforms
and sometimes on desktop just now we
said a Chrome OS right and sometimes
html5 platforms Council or even VR the
next difference is that we have we got
less support from third-party I mean
such as test frameworks or testing tools
and platforms
unlike apps Google provide app
developers with test frameworks like
your Automator or espresso and also
testing tools are integrated in Android
studio and also we have firebase test
lab for app testing another big issue is
that games always need more test cases
because users there are more content
that can be played in in a game than in
an app so the test cases are increases
exponentially in games so how do we
solve these issues we can hire more and
more people to do testing but hiring
more people to do tests on 200 Android
phones
that's not tolerable I think even if
it's in China so we can so automation is
here to help actually we have developed
this project for three years internally
and last year on Google i/o and I talked
with firebase test lab team and we
cooperate open source in this project so
let me introduce a test IDE first it's a
desktop IDE the left the right side is
the mirror window of an Android phone
connecting with your PC via ADB and the
middle part is a code editor where you
can write average for python code and
the left part shows the hierarchy of
this the UI hierarchy of this unity game
and also the API is provided by our test
framework and when you operate on the
screen window testicle will be
automatically generated on the in the
code editor let's see the demo click the
recording button and perform a touch
action it will generate a sentence in
Python
also you can agitate a swipe action and
then we can sleep one second also make
assertions of the UI show up
yes then we can write it immediately on
this form to see if it works after you
run the tests yeah it worked after you
write you can share the HTML report it
shows every step of your tests yeah if
any step went wrong it will be labeled
red and you can see the failure point
you may have noticed that we have to we
have to underline test framework here
the first thing is it has the framework
it uses image recognition have a
knowledge to locate the UI elements and
then the use device API to perform
simulated input yes this is the
structure of a test we provide users
with simple test api like a simulator
input like making sushi and then it uses
image recognition to locate the UI and
then we have a underlying abstract layer
of platform api we unify the
simulating input api's of different
platforms so that user can run their
script on different platforms like
Android iOS and Windows and we are there
is another framework called poco this
this framework is similar to the test
frameworks for apps like your Automator
for full Android but most games uses a
graphic api like OpenGL or Vulcan to
render their UI widget so we can
directly use your out mater
our Android for games so we developed
oakum yeah this is how it works
we also have a underlying abstract layer
of device abstraction here for different
game engines we provide each game engine
and SDK so that the test framework can
communicate with the game engine we are
JSON JSON RPC and then we unify a
different game engines so we can write
tests for different game engines yeah
also the custom engines in the morning
eyes I saw most of you are using custom
engines we provide multiple language SDK
so you can implement in your own game
managing and start using our test
framework and also our tools now here is
a comparison it has to use image
recognition to locate UI and use
platform API to perform simulated input
and what's cool here is it does not
require any instrumentation just plug in
your phone and start using and we
support multiple platforms and Poco uses
your hierarchy inspection and use JSON
RPC to communicate with the SDK in game
engine
now you need to integrate our SDK in it
usually takes less than ten minutes and
now we support unity and Coco's this two
game engine and also Android native app
we use we implement an SDK using
accessibility service so you don't need
to integrate anything into your app for
Android native apps and also custom game
engine so how do you choose which
framework to use here are some
suggestions from us actually in that is
we have written thousands of tests for
different type of games internally and
the advantage of EDS is obvious it's a
requires no instrumentation and using
open CV to do to do assertion to make
assertion of the UI is reliable because
it checks exactly what users are
expected to see and for poco Sin City
uses you our hierarchy inspection it can
be more accurate especially for cases of
a 3d object when the objects change
their orientation in games yeah and this
project this poco is similar to test
frameworks for apps like a cure
Automation and it covers the what is
missing for games and we released this
to a project on GDC two month ago and we
got six thousand downloads and over one
hundred one thousand stars in this two
month and please try our project and
star assange it hub but is that it we
have two more new features in this two
month first we support iOS actually we
have supported ours last year but the
performance is not
good enough to release to be released
let's see this demo you're connecting
your iOS with your Xcode then you can
operate the screen just like for Android
phones
and this is one of our games
then you can run the tests on this
iPhone
that's it the back end of this iOS
support is origin originated from
Facebook web driver agent by the web
driver agent is the problem is is that
is too slow a simple touch action can
take as long as one second and it's not
tolerable for games automation so we
optimize most of its API last last month
and now the frame rate can be up to 15
fps in the add has ID another feature is
we support web pages automation you can
open the Chrome browser in the IDE and
then you can operate on the Chrome and
then the hole will be automatically
generated yeah the superb is based on
selenium framework also you can use it
has the API to make assertions
to run the test and then generate the
report since
selenium is a quite material in web
pages automation we have no reason to
reinvent it so we just write we just
wrote a plug-in for a test IDE to to
help recording these web pages
automation right I think he will be
useful if you are releasing game on HTML
platform until now we talked about a
test project you can use a test IDE to
record and and run the test on your PC
and on your phone but how do it has to
hang the reserved Android phones the
first thing is firebase test lab
firebase test lab is a test service
provided by Google firebase team and
what we do cooperating with their team
is we support running a test and poco
script on firebase test lab and you can
use artists ID to bundle your your test
script into an apk and then you can
upload it to the FTL webpage and then
you can start an instrumentation test
and use the cloud of devices provided by
FTL and this is our internal device form
we have we have set up a device form of
200 devices to have Android devices and
we have written now the number could be
2006 and we run those scripts of
different games every week because our
game are updated weekly and let's see
how it works
yeah
it's just soft game and around the test
generated by adversity
yeah that's it as for our roadmap for
this automation project we are intended
we intended to support more clients iOS
Android emulator and web pages these are
in beta version you can try it now and
feel free to to fire us a issue if you
find any pack and also we are hybrid
apps in Unreal Engine it's in the future
also we supported we supported Android
TV but I'm not sure about Chrome OS but
maybe it works and also another
important thing is we we we want to
build up the open-source community for
this project and I hope more and more
developers like it and get involved in
this project yeah thank you and any
question
you mentioned you're using the
accessibility service did you have any
issue with that when that was restricted
recently the accessibility service it
was restricted for apps that were using
those launchers or for any apps that
we're trying to access the reverse color
tap to enlarge those are things that
were being restricted because they were
being taken advantage of
have you guys seen any impact from that
for you are testing with for your
testing of native apps we don't see any
restriction I think it's it can do what
you are automation oh it special - yeah